our first um Summit our conference that
we conducted and I kept telling my
friends from the health ecosystem well
we're having an event around fentic and
I'm like what what is I'm getting these
feedbacks of what is fintech you mean
and I'm like no fem Tech female Women's
Health that's what we need it sounds
like niche
seriously 51 of the world is a niche
sector no no no no dudes you've got it
wrong and this is kind of where it
started off welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today I'm with Sharon Handelman
Gottlieb Healthcare and aging business
manager at sample digital lab Tel Aviv
as well as a leader in the Israeli
femtech Community promoting Women's
Health and Israeli femtech ecosystems
welcome Sharon
I'm really excited especially for
episode where I get to dive into
subjects that I don't normally get to
discuss and I and I have a feeling that
that
um feeling or as we're going to start
looking at the market of femtech and
what's been happening over the last few
years years
with the rise I don't know if it's the
rise has been as good as you would have
as you'd perhaps have liked from coming
within the industry but I'm anyways
excited to learn about your own
perspective your own journey and what's
happening today so Sharon before we even
get started about femtech and aging tell
me a little bit about yourself and how
do you perceive your role in this
ecosystem
sure
um so my day job is at sombo digital lab
Tel Aviv which is part of the sample
Holdings corporate sample is a very
large one of the largest in fact
Japanese insurance companies based in
Tokyo the headquarters and then
operating in over 30 countries on a
global basis and the uniqueness of sumpo
is the fact that they have the largest
Home Care Network in Japan so aging and
Japan is really a key Focus area for for
them and as part of the kind of vision
of the company to define the future and
to play a key
contributor to the Future they've
established this mission to focus on
impact areas which some of them are
around my key a predominant areas which
are Health aging and and the like which
is my background basically tell me about
the background so getting into to the
space that you're in it doesn't sound
like the most the most conventional
space to be in even if you're in
healthcare maybe I'm wrong but that's
just an intuition how did you get into
this space what led this
and are you talking to are you
addressing femtex specifically or just
generally speaking well femtech aging
deciding to go into Healthcare initially
even sure so I started off at leading
the Innovation at maccabi's institution
research and Innovation KSM and I led
there The Innovation and kind of
developed some cool new spaces I tried
to create a new a new world the
combining gaming and health is part of
the covet battle that was my personal
kind of contribution and I love
exploring new areas and
um new territories in the field of
Health which is my focus area this is
why I wake up in the morning and when I
try to do uh better for a better world
and then in the midst of kovid I kind of
came across a post
around femtic who wants to join the
Israeli community and then I started to
explore this um this new ecosystem
Rising on a global basis saying
wow this seems like
written all over my name
um because the combination or actually
the triangle of feminism Women's Health
Innovation and and and health all that
together is what I really believe in
trying to fight the Battle of equality
support health and support Innovation
and I said boom this is where I'd like
to focus so I put my energy into that a
lot of my time my my kind of um
my private time to focus on that to
learn to study and to impact this um
this space by raising the awareness by
creating new spaces new opportunities
for entrepreneurs for investors and also
kind of Dipping my hands as well even as
part of of my my role to creating new
Mini startups or new modules algorithms
to support Women's Health
talk to me a little bit about horizontal
versus vertical depth so when you're
looking today at the so I was saying
there's just
okay well
we're gonna be able to attend this out
of course if we're looking at
the world of femtech and we're looking
at your personal passion so now we sort
of like entrepreneurial entrepreneur I'm
trying to figure out your decision to
what it sounds like to to examine a
variety of different solutions be on a
more Community basis work with a variety
of entrepreneurs
talk to me a little bit about that
decision and respect to the potential of
maybe diving into one very specific
problem and executing on that what is
that dissonance for you and and how did
you how did you make your decision there
sure so the decision was fit was fairly
easy
understanding that we're
underrepresented as women
and we've been ignored historically for
so many reasons for so long
that got me kind of wired and got me
saying you know what this is my place to
be because when we started off and
kicking off even in Israel only our
first um Summit our conference that we
conducted and I kept telling my friends
from the health ecosystem while we're
having an event around fentic and I'm
like what what is I'm getting these
feedbacks up what is fintech you mean
and I'm like no fem Tech female Women's
Health that's what we need and and then
why do we need that and it sounds like
niche
seriously 51 of the world is a niche
sector no no no no no dudes you've got
it wrong and this is kind of where it
started off
understanding that
there aren't there isn't enough
representation for women's health issues
challenges and even if you dive into the
space the sectors the sub-sectors of
femtic and see that they're focused on
very particular areas and spaces meaning
that
it's around cycle management it's around
pregnancy it's around reproductive
what are we only a vessel a womb to to
bring their children explain that by the
way what led to this to these being the
primary cause I have my own hypothesis
but I'm curious to hear what what why
you think well there
are other reasons I I think
um those are the most easier topics to
discuss
and there are not taboo
um and that men get more because men are
the ones it's shifting but used to be
more I'm happy to say it's less of an
issue but it's still an issue are the
ones in the funds in the VCS controlling
that so they get pregnancy they get
cycle management they don't get
menopause they don't get endometriosis
even the medical space and
um and Millie don't get that or haven't
they haven't been getting that so so
fast up until recently so I think the
decision was to choose the ones which
are more consensus less of an issue yeah
which makes more sense to be monetized
even though that is wrong and I would
challenge that dramatically so I think
that was mainly the reason and also the
fact that there's tremendous lack of
data gender bias taboo
even the simple understanding for us
women we don't understand our own
biology we don't understand what we
underestimate the challenges or the
symptoms that we're facing
and
her makeup or how we've been taught to
live our lives is to kind of just endure
pain or endorse it and say this is it I
can give you a simple a simple example
for that as well let's say a topic which
is now finally being heard and being
voiced louder and clear is a chronic
condition called endometriosis I won't
get into what it is and what are the
implications but the fact of the matter
is the 10 percent of women suffer from
endometriosis
the diagnostic stage the diet the way in
the way it's diagnosed and the duration
of that time period is 7.5 years
to diagnose the woman
of being at an endometriosis chronic
condition patient 7.5 I can't think of
an equivalent in male kind of categories
that would take so long
and the journey a very hellish one
is is the journey that expects was
expected for a woman to go through until
she's diagnosed as an injury
endometriosis patient which is unheard
of and even that the way it's being
diagnosed today is through surgery
which again is crazy
years of suffering years of pain years
of neglect with correct collateral
damage to associate to that is just
something that we cannot accept anymore
so these are kind of the the examples I
can give around those topics
if we're looking at what's happening now
then with the emergence of all this
information because I think you just you
mentioned a sentence so a few minutes
ago that a lot of women don't even know
their own biology
um I'm sure that most men don't know I
tried I know my biology but
but a lot of the terms that you said you
I'm sure will be new to both men and
women I'm curious
you're saying something very simple
you're saying listen there's 51 of the
world having having are exposed to these
potential issues some of them have a as
high as 10 percent you know of the
market is experiencing them obviously
this is a and sorry for my French I get
crap ton of money you know this is any
Investor's dream is that the reaction of
investors as they're now learning this
are they sort of like big wide open eyes
and saying yes let's run is that what's
happening it's finally getting closer to
that I think today when we
um when we come up to investors to VCS
as femtech and entrepreneurs and new
ideas now they're getting the market and
not considering it a niche and they'll
give a very great example what you just
um refer to which is fully accurate
let's talk about menopause up until now
it was a topic
fully ignored by women by by the medical
space Again by investors this is a huge
Market a billion market value rate value
valuation it's every woman around the
world to reach the point which she is
facing menopause and the applic the
implications of that on Society on the
economics on women's health in itself
are dramatic so even if you look at that
from a business perspective and
understand that this is a huge Market
investors are saying wow yeah let's see
let's see what what is there out there
now not much I'll say and what we can do
yes bring me menopause Solutions please
so that's the narrative that we're
hearing today and that's the shift a
dramatic one which I'm happy about
what are we expecting
from me from your perspective let's say
be a little optimistic or or not you
also maybe it'll surprise me what what
changes are we going to experience over
the next few years that are going to
shift the way we're gonna experience
this field femtech how is this gonna you
know infiltrate sort of the world order
and change things here
so I'll give my optimistic side of
things it will shift and it will be
better
for a variety of reasons I think the the
first one is the fact that we're seeing
it now first of all it's growing and
there are more women
picking up their game stepping up and
claiming the space saying we have
challenges we have issues we have
problems we want to solve them for
ourselves so it's not somebody else
doing the job for us it's we doing what
we need to do for ourselves as women
that's one the second thing would be the
expansion
categories and topics so it's not only
the three categories that I mentioned
before it will be the expansion into new
territories like mental health issues
focused on on and women migrants which
is a Chrono condition
more painful for for women rather than
than men is three times three times more
affecting women wow um I have no idea
yeah I can give you numbers staggering
numbers I think in any health category
okay you're ready for that
let's go
so what would you think would be
deathclaws number one for women
wow I'm gonna I can't answer these
questions this is going on record I'm
gonna be wrong on like everything I need
you to just give me the answers so I'll
give you the answer
it's the first the debt the first number
one death cause is heart attacks is
cardiovascular events okay okay
but
when we
think of let's say
series television series around ER right
or the good doctor and we think of a
heart attack what do you think give me
your what what's the the top state
what's the top symptom what would you
feel
a heart attack shooting pains down one
of my arms I forget which one it is okay
the second one give me another one
the second symptom
no I sent him the most obvious one
you would probably feel chest pains
right yeah chest pain heart pumping
chest pain yes and then you'd go to the
doctor run or rush to the ER and say I'm
9-1-1
chest pains and they'll rush you through
the procedures right well the fact of
the matter is that 40 of women don't
feel chest pains no when they're
undergoing a heart attack wow and their
symptoms are totally different
so crazy if we're not having the chest
pains and if we've been taught
I'm gonna look this up later look it up
I'm fine it's backed up believe me and
when you feel nauseous or kind of
stressed or other conditions that you
feel and you'd go to the doctor and
they'd kind of dismiss you saying no
you're under a rough time maybe you're
undergoing a lot of pressure at work go
back go over go relax go rest
but the likelihood of you going through
a heart attack or any kind of additional
you know other condition under the the
cardiovascular area
there's a highly likelihood but we are
being dismissed and even going to the ER
is going through a procedure of a longer
waiting time along a long and
undiagnosed of wrong diagnosis of what
where what a woman would undergo and
then sent home
with the wrong medication why is that I
can give you the story of that for
another 20 minutes I think that's a
different interview altogether so even
the simple things that are not women
oriented it doesn't talk about the
ovarian or the uterus the or you know a
breast cancer so it's a typical
I'd say consensus
chronic disease
but it's different and we're not aware
of that
not the not not the the not women not
men not the medical clinicians
it's all wrong and this is the thing
that we're going to see a dramatic shift
in change in the future in the next few
years that's one example again I can
give you the whole portray of how I see
things but I'm fully optimistic about
them
your your vision for yourself in the
coming years what is your role in the
space I mean you're obviously you know
incredibly passionate about about this
whole Space extremely knowledgeable you
practice it you are you know you as a is
a as a world athlete because the the
things that you're doing as an athlete
are world class I mean they're you're at
like the top zero one percent you you
are very intentional about the things
that you do so I know the the passion
and the motivation that you bring just
from just from the athletic background
that you briefly shared with me before
and before we started the podcast how
are you channeling that energy towards a
personal vision for what you want to do
in the space
I Channel it and and I love this
question because I always like to see
things as I do
um as a non-professional athlete let's
say a marathon runner you know it takes
you have to see the vision and the end
kind of end game the the ultimate goal
of reaching the 42
but taking it very slowly
very well planned
and um and accept also the hardship in
the in in the way yeah the challenges
the
um the failures if you have a bad run
and but but focus on what you need and
this is how I see it planning it one
step one step at the time building it as
a really defined Marathon kind of
program and plan and that's how I see it
so expanding the networks getting more
people aware of that bringing in the
technology
experts professionals the the medical
space all together with investors and
kind of bringing it so we see the
circles expand and more and more join
this mission
and and and believe in it and and see
the numbers
again if it's from a scientific side if
it's from an economic side it doesn't
matter but whoever can join that and
start running together to bring the to
bring this into a brighter future this
is how I see it
um and this is how I believe in it
incredible so on there really a awesome
time 20 minutes not nearly enough and I
you're leaving me you know hanging with
it I need so the whole heart attack
thing that that's pretty wild I mean it
really I mean
and this is something that pretty much
every you know I'm guessing that um any
person would have you know a similar
reaction to the one that I was having
because I think that what really is the
the the the the stressful part here
is that this is the portrayal in mass
media for so long this is what the
average person would think and this is
literally a life and death situation
this is I think you know um
it's going to leave me thinking for a
while and that's exactly why I do this
show and so so thank you for giving me
some really interesting insights
um definitely going to be continuing
this in my families for about dinner
tomorrow it's Gonna Keep Us busy and I
really appreciate your time your energy
and the work that you're doing for this
whole industry and I am excited to
continue trying from the side so thank
you thank you so much for having me and
and and being patient around temtek talk
thank you thank you Siobhan
[Music]